[Música]
se cumplen diez años desde que el
cardenal Jorge Mario bergoglio de
nacionalidad Argentina fue elegido como
papa de la Iglesia Católica
bergoglio adoptó el nombre de Francisco
y sería el encargado de reemplazar al
Papa Benedicto 16 quien inesperadamente
en su momento renunció a su cargo debido
a su avanzada edad y a su condición
física Francisco se convirtió así en el
primer pontífice latinoamericano y
también en el primer pontífice jesuita
en la historia en asumir ese cargo su
pontificado pues se ha caracterizado por
los cambios al interior del Vaticano
también porque su mirada es un poco más
moderna y genera divisiones tanto al
interior de la Iglesia Católica como
institución y del Vaticano como un
estado ha visitado 60 países en 40
viajes a lo largo de estos 10 años
principalmente países con serias
dificultades y problemas internos como
lo son por ejemplo la República
centroafricana en África y del sur a lo
largo de esta década Francisco ha hecho
frente también a diferentes crisis Como
esos innumerables denuncias de abuso
sexual por parte de integrantes de la
Iglesia Católica También las denuncias
de muerte de menores de edad en
residencias administradas por la iglesia
católica tanto en Canadá como en Irlanda
y ha debatido sobre temas muy
controvertidos Como por ejemplo el
aborto la homosexualidad y también ha
tomado ciertas posiciones frente a
algunos gobernantes ya veremos Cuáles
también ha sido testigo del inicio de
conflictos como la actual guerra en
Ucrania y del paso de una devastadora
pandemia como lo fue la pandemia del
cobi 19 en 10 años el Papa Francisco
controvertido querido criticado admirado
sigue siendo una figura relevante en la
escena internacional a pesar de la
diversidad de opiniones que genera por
eso hoy en el debate de France 24 vamos
a analizar esta primera década del Papa
Francisco sus luchas sus logros sus
aciertos sus los aciertos frente a la
iglesia católica para analizar este tema
hemos invitado Álvaro ramis el esteólogo
y rector de la universidad ha cambiado
academia de humanismo Cristiano se
conecta desde la ciudad de Santiago
capital de chile y desde la ciudad de
Viña del Mar también en chile se conecta
Pedro Pablo achondo Moya él es teólogo
asesor de comunidades especialista en
ecología integral y teología
latinoamericana recuerden ustedes
nuestros televidentes que también son
parte de este debate ustedes pueden
dejar sus comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
Twitter en Facebook en instagram nos
encuentran como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios numeral el debate f-24 a
mí en Twitter me encuentran como arroba
santilogo no olviden también que todos
los contenidos de este programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
pues comienzo entonces dándole la
bienvenida a Álvaro en la ciudad de
Santiago la capital de Chile para
comenzar en Álvaro como Punto de partida
para este debate Cuál es el balance que
usted hace a grandes rasgos de estos
primeros 10 años de pontificado de
Francisco
Bueno yo quisiera Resaltar que es bonito
importante para América Latina Más allá
de la figura de Francisco y del de su
relevancia para la iglesia es relevante
para América Latina que un
latinoamericano tenga una estatura y un
rol de gobierno global hay poca
personalidades o figuras
latinoamericanas que han podido tener
esta relevancia podríamos decir que
existen latinoamericanos universales en
el ámbito de la ciencia de la cultura de
la poesía de las artes o del fútbol
Pelé un Maradona un Messi pero tener a
alguien a cargo de una institución
influye en la vida concreta de las
personas todo el mundo al mismo tiempo
desde África hasta Estados Unidos desde
Europa hasta América Latina es algo
inédito y creo que eso es importante de
valorar respecto al al proceso que ha
llevado adelante el Papa Francisco Yo
creo que es esa ambigüedad de tratar de
hacer cambios en una institución que
parece resistirlos o sea a mí me da la
impresión de que el papa está tres pasos
adelante y la iglesia como entendida
como institución los obispos Ah el clero
pareciera estar solamente uno adelante o
incluso a veces Un paso atrás sí Y esa
es una una marca de este pontificado
ese es un tema que vamos a analizar más
adelante aquí en el programa le doy la
palabra a Pedro Pablo en la ciudad de
Viña del Mar también el mismo Punto de
partida Cuál es el balance que usted
hace de esta primera década de
pontificado de Francisco
bueno aprovecho de saludarte Santiago
saludar a Álvaro también
Sí yo me sumo un poco las palabras de
Álvaro creo que el balance sumando
restando que siempre es complejo no
sería positivo
desde el punto de vista
eclesial incluso Sí Más allá de la
barreras de la iglesia Francisco ha
traído esperanza no son diez años de un
aire de renuevo un aire de frescor
por un lado por ser latinoamericano sin
duda Pero también por las ideas que le
ha traído por los temas que ha colocado
Entonces yo partiría diciendo que que es
un saldo positivo evidentemente imagino
que vamos a hablar hay temas pendientes
pero pero de que él marca una Pauta de
renovación y de una oxigenación a la
iglesia no me cabe ninguna duda
Pedro Pablo continuó con usted para
hacer la ronda a la inversa hablemos
entonces de ese hay de renovador que
usted ha dicho en su En su comentario
ese aire más moderno y también un poco
con ese sentido latinoamericano que le
ha dado el padre el Papa Francisco a la
Iglesia Católica y ahí mismo también le
añado Cuáles pueden ser como los grandes
logros que ha tenido el Papa Francisco a
lo largo de estos 10 años que usted
pueda recordar tres o cuatro grandes
puntos que usted pueda Resaltar
sí partiría diciendo el proyecto
eclesial del Papa Francisco es decir la
idea que él está proponiendo de iglesia
es bastante diferente de lo que de lo
que ya estaba establecido entonces
primer punto Ah desde el interior no en
cuanto a reforma y como te digo respiro
una nueva imagen cuando él dice por
ejemplo la iglesia hospital de campaña
una iglesia de de puerta abierta cercana
a los jóvenes que se equivoque
misericordiosa decir está lleno de
imágenes que él usa para para dar cuenta
de esta nueva propuesta eclesial segundo
la ecología no esto aparece el 2015 con
los datos sí hubo un tema jamás tocado
de esta manera no a nivel de encíclica y
documento oficial de la iglesia que sin
duda es una marca no es una marca ya sea
por el nombre que él elige Francisco en
una alusión explícita a Francisco de
Asís y también por los contenidos que él
y el interés ese es un segundo tema
después yo diría
el tema político no es un papa que ha
intervenido o ha querido dialogar ha
querido ser intermediario en un montón
de conflictos sociopolítico
fundamentales no se me viene a la cabeza
lampedusa con los migrantes el conflicto
en un momento el cierre de frontera a
Cuba entre Estados Unidos
bueno guerras es decir es un papa que
está metido en la contingencia que le
interesa marcar la Pauta En búsqueda de
la paz de la reconciliación y la
justicia esos tres temas Se podría decir
por ahora Álvaro su opinión adelante
Sí coincido con Pedro Pablo y además
resaltaría los temas internos de la
curia Romana ya
la necesidad de una reforma a la
estructura de poder interno de la
iglesia banco Vaticano y todos los
problemas que ha tenido que enfrentar
respecto a
problemas históricos de blanqueo de
capitales problemas que están arraigados
en gestiones anteriores Y que él ha
tenido que cargar con la pesada mochila
de limpiar las finanzas en ese ámbito
más oscuro otro elemento son tratar de
de asumir la crítica Respecto a los
abusos sexuales del clero y en ese
ámbito obviamente los resultados Son son
mediocres son ambiguos pero no ha
faltado voluntad creo que ahí se ha
topado con la posturas de la institución
y no da el ancho a la hora de asumir sus
propias consecuencias de sus propias
decisiones generales hay hay un tema por
lo tanto pendiente pero que creo que
la acción de Papa Francisco en general
yo la valoro Aunque obviamente la
Iglesia Católica en eso todavía tiene
mucho que avanzar en reconocimiento
en generar condiciones de reparación a
las víctimas y de establecer también
verdades oficiales
Álvaro en ese sentido qué tan
a la par están marchando esas propuestas
del Papa Francisco esa renovación ese
cambio ese nuevo aire que le quiere dar
a la iglesia católica como institución y
la velocidad con la que se mueve
justamente la Iglesia Católica al
interior y todo lo que se mueve dentro
del Vaticano para tratar de renovar
actualizar o por lo menos darle una
especie de actualización a la a la
institución como tal en torno a los
debates que se dan en la sociedad actual
en posiciones que tiene también el
Vaticano y la iglesia frente a
discusiones que se dan en diferentes
rincones del planeta van a la par el
papa le cuesta mucho y tiene que jalonar
mucho al Vaticano de la iglesia para que
den un paso para que puedan tomar una
decisión y Mostrar ese aire digámoslo
así de un poco más de modernidad
Así es Y además eso tiene una variable
geográfica la Iglesia Católica es una
institución global una de las
instituciones más grandes del mundo
estamos hablando de mil trescientos
millones de personas que se escriben al
catolicismo y hay países tal vez como
Alemania por ejemplo que va más adelante
que Francisco que exige avanzar muy
rápido Ah hace pocos días vimos que a
partir del 2026 van a comenzar a
bendecir pareja gay en cambio en otros
países por ejemplo en Polonia en Hungría
o en algunas zonas de Estados Unidos la
iglesia pareciera querer involucionar y
mucho más lento incluso Volver atrás
entonces armonizar Esas dificultades de
países que quieren avanzar más rápido
con otros que parecen ir muy lentos O
tal vez para atrás Es una difícil
emisión el papa justamente lo que trata
de hacer es mantener la unidad de una
institución tan amplia tan grande
de escala global con países con
intereses convicciones internas muy
Pedro su opinión sobre esta velocidad
entre estas dos entre estas dos pares
entre estos dos piezas fundamentales que
son el papa y la institución y el
Vaticano como tal Y yo a eso le añado
otro factor que eso viene tal vez del
lado de Los Seguidores de la iglesia y
es si hay un cierto grado de crisis de
fe o de admiración hacia la institución
que el papa todavía no ha logrado
reversarse Sigue perdiendo la cantidad
de feligreses hay datos que así lo
revelan
sí voy a partir por atrás
a ver yo creo que hay que hacer una
diferencia que no siempre se hace y a
veces ni siquiera se entiende que tiene
que ver entre la iglesia
como institución de lo que tú me estás
preguntando porque estamos hablando del
Papa mejor digamos del obispo de Roma y
que a su vez hace de de cabeza de los
obispos Y de alguna forma la cara
visible del catolicismo latino no
pero otra cosa es el seguimiento de
Jesús Entonces cuando hablamos de fe yo
creo que hay que hacer esa distinción es
decir la fe en Jesús y yo no sé si se ha
diluido Se ha perdido está deambulando
sin rumbo no lo creo no yo yo veo Yo veo
que todavía hay testimonios hay testigos
hay
hay pasión y finalmente hay hay amor no
digamos en el vínculo con Jesús de
Nazaret y el proyecto del cristianismo
en general otra cosa de la iglesia da
cuenta yo sé que es una distinción
difícil de hacer y incluso hay debates
internos es que es posible hacerla no yo
creo que sí sí se puede y hay que
hacerla porque efectivamente hay una una
crisis digamos respecto de la
pertenencia a la institución eclesial
eso no me cabe ninguna duda y la gente
de alguna manera no quiere participar de
una iglesia
que se manifiesta como como Abusiva es
decir o como cómplice de abuso Una
institución que que es poderosa que
maneja
una estructura milenaria pero al mismo
tiempo pesada gigante más parecida a un
imperio entonces ahí está el tema no
decir finalmente esta iglesia con este
ropaje y todo lo que conocemos nos
permite conocer a Jesús de Nazaret nos
permite acercarnos al mensaje del
cristianismo o no
Y si la gente responde que sí Bueno
Sigue adelante si la gente responde que
no entra en crisis y finalmente se
desvincula afectivamente de la iglesia
institucional pero sigue participando
desde su fe en comunidades cristianas
sin duda en el seguimiento de Jesús
entiende entonces ahí hay un tema así
interesante que
que que que afinar no en la discusión
que estamos teniendo después para
responder lo segundo rápidamente
creo que en ese sentido Francisco Sí
Busca que nos acerquemos a Jesús si
busca que no se pierda esa adherencia
pero al mismo tiempo él está dentro y y
no sobre todo dentro digamos él es la
cabeza de esta institución que le estoy
comentando Entonces yo creo que
Francisco está ahí no En una atención
interna Álvaro lo decía muy profunda No
él no puede hacer mucho más de lo que ya
ha hecho y eso es lamentable porque yo
creo que él tiene buena idea tiene buena
voluntad
pero al mismo tiempo sigue siendo el
papa claro y y se debe a un público
para terminar un público que que ama
esta cosa
Imperial y triunfal y al mismo tiempo un
público que busca un cristianismo mal
modo de las comunidades primitivas Dónde
dónde está el papa no cómo se ubican
sí me quedo con lo de una atención Pedro
Pablo porque eso me lleva a esa atención
interna porque justamente hace 10 años
cuando Francisco llegó a para iniciar
este pontificado Álvaro
muchos decían que este nuevo papa en ese
momento hace una década estoy hablando
No representaba justamente a esos
obispos y a esos Cardenales al interior
del Vaticano que para nada Es un secreto
todas estas movidas medio truculentas
que hay dentro de el sistema financiero
que tiene el Vaticano los bancos quienes
depositan allí el dinero y lo que
representa esto para para la
desaparición de capitales a nivel
internacional etcétera tema aparte que
no vamos a debatir pero que el Papa
Francisco Sí representaba al pueblo no
representaba estos intereses de Los
Cardenales y los obispos en estos 10
años el papa Ha logrado consagrar ese
puente entre el pueblo y la institución
Usted cree que lo ha logrado hacer
Álvaro
yo creo que lo ha intentado pero la
brechas son muy grandes decir la
relación la distancia que también
describía Pedro Pablo no en la
institución y el la masa el pueblo
católico global universal es bastante
profunda y el poder también de la
institucionalidad Católica muchas veces
entran contradicción con la necesidad de
esa misma institución de renovarse y de
re legitimar su rol en la sociedad
Entonces el papa está sometido digamos a
una Misión Imposible renovar Una
institución que a su vez pelea por
mantenerse en los factores que la llevan
a ver legitimarse que son el secretismo
la forma de gestión alejada por decirlo
así del sentido común de la sociedad con
prácticas anacrónica y que ha quebrado
por decirlo así la sintonía fina con las
nuevas generaciones entonces obviamente
la pregunta que habría que hacerse es
que hubiera pasado si no hubiéramos
Bienvenido a Francisco en estos diez
años yo creo que la velocidad con la
cual la iglesia hubiera perdido
relevancia y capacidad de legitimación
en la sociedad hubiera sido mucho mayor
es decir Francisco ha mitigado los los
efectos de una larga decadencia pero no
lo ha logrado revertir porque sería una
labor demasiado grande para un solo
hombre claro eso eso creo que va en
sintonía con mi siguiente Pregunta
Álvaro continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda la inversa Y es que
particularmente este pontificado de
Francisco ha dado espacio para debates
que han sido muy álgidos en la sociedad
en los diferentes países del Mundo temas
Como por ejemplo el aborto el matrimonio
igualitario la homosexualidad justamente
estos abusos estas denuncias de abuso
que chile fue un gran protagonista a
nivel internacional de estas denuncias
de abusos por parte de integrantes del
clero a menores de edad que son hechos
que vienen de décadas atrás y el papá
Francisco ha salido a ponerle la cara en
nombre de la institución a este tipo de
problemas eso va en sintonía creo con lo
que usted menciona esto también ha
mejorado la imagen de la iglesia cree
que ha contribuido en ese en ese
acercamiento con con el pueblo con con
la gente mostrando una iglesia un poco
más abierta Escuchar Aunque claramente
hay voces que lo siguen criticando por
la posición un poco tibia digámoslo Así
que tiene sobre esos temas
Sí por supuesto obviamente muchos
quisiéramos que el papa fuera mucho más
rápido y fuera mucho más radical en sus
posiciones sin embargo debemos
considerar que se trata de una
institución tan amplia y tan grande
donde debe armonizar ante todo el
criterio de unidad la diversidad y por
lo tanto mantener esa unidad exige
muchas veces no avanzar tan rápido como
se quisiera recordemos solo un hecho
hace algunos años se realizó el sino de
la amazonía que junto con hablar de los
problemas
ecosociales o los problemas ecológicos y
sociales que afectan a América Latina
también habló de la posibilidad de
introducir un claro casado o introducir
unas primeras prácticas de sacerdotes
casados en algunas zonas de frontera y
la oposición que tuvo de a los sectores
más conservadores del del cardenalato de
obispos Ah fue muy radical muy fuerte y
por lo tanto tuvo que detener ese
proceso Es una lástima porque justamente
una de las pensiones que afectan al
catolicismo es la imposibilidad de
mantener el clero incluso
demográficamente la cantidad de
sacerdotes que hoy día tienen que cubrir
las diócesis cada vez baja más está
extinguiendo y si no hay un cambio en la
disciplina que tiene que ver con el
matrimonio Eso va a llevar
necesariamente a que no va a haber clero
suficiente para poder cubrir las
necesidades básicas de la sociedad y por
lo tanto esa oposición a la reforma que
quiere impulsar el Papa Francisco
También total digamos contradicción con
los intereses de sobrevivencia a la
institución pero pareciera ser que
ciertos sectores no advierten las
consecuencias de su posición al papa
Álvaro rápidamente ya le doy la palabra
Pedro pero para cerrar este tema a quién
le interesa que esta reformas no se
lleven a cabo que estos cambios no se
lleven a cabo al interior de la iglesia
yo creo que hay intereses particulares
que se anteponen a los intereses
generales sí la el interés general de la
iglesia Debería ser su reforma en
función de su actualización tal cual fue
el espíritu del Vaticano segundo cuando
el papa Juan 23 abrió puertas y ventanas
para que entrara un aire fresco y
pudiera actualizarse la vida
eclesial y hoy día pareciera fuerzas no
destinadas a mantener el estado pudo por
más bien por un una comodidad no la
sensación de estar en un gueto muy
cómodo para las personas que están ahí
Pedro retornó la con usted en la
comunicación aquí en el debate y su
opinión sobre este tema estos temas
importantes para la sociedad actual que
ya lo mencionaba yo el aborto el
matrimonio igualitario la homosexualidad
sobre estos temas se ha pronunciado el
papa
sí Mira yo creo que el papa
a ver dos cosas el papa por un lado
él está empapado del espíritu
latinoamericano ya por decirlo de alguna
forma es decir el papa conoce los
barrios argentinos fue párroco participó
en procesiones digo esto porque el
perfil de Francisco ya es un perfil
diferente No de hecho en Europa se decía
Francisco no es un teólogo como era
ratzinger Ah o no no tiene la altura que
tenía que se yo entonces efectivamente
él ha popularizado
a al llegar a Roma una manera un rostro
de la iglesia distinto que yo te diría
en gran parte de Europa era desconocido
no era desconocido porque yo tuve la
suerte de vivir en un tiempo en Francia
y y se producía este ruido con este papa
tan parroquial no tan cercano tan
un poco protocolar tan espontáneo
Entonces te digo esto porque él él trae
América Latina con lo que es y eso ya
manifiesta una figura de pastor
de Obispo distinto por un lado de eso
sin embargo eso no logra no logra
permear en en aspectos que que están
como por debajo de la de la institución
católica no Y estos aspectos Son son
éticos Son teológicos son
eclesiales son culturales entonces digo
esto porque porque Francisco no ha
logrado creo yo no ha logrado
modificar o de alguna manera reformar Si
se quiere esta palabra o ayunar temas
como los que tú me preguntas no la
discusión sobre el aborto el matrimonio
igualitario
la eutanasia
y muchos otros no muchos otros
ideología de género que él habla te das
cuenta uno diría Por qué el papa se
refiere así a ese tema no
quién lo está asesorando que está
leyendo entonces no es solo él no él él
está parado en una estructura que es
teológica que es magisterial y trata de
moverse dentro de esa cancha con con
dificultad no contención entonces
probablemente el papa es mucho más de
Avanzada de lo que de lo que parece ser
Supongo no Espero y si no tenemos que
esperar un siglo más no un siglo más
para que estos temas en lugar de la
mujer por ejemplo es inconcebible Es
inconcebible que no sea un tema de
actualidad claro una Claro en una
estructura tan patriarcal de varones
célibes que se escogen a sí mismo te das
cuenta de una cosa que hoy día ninguna
institución lo lo acepta Sí justamente
Pedro Le iba a preguntar por por esas
deudas pendientes que tiene el papa a lo
largo de estos diez años cosas que le
faltan por hacer y justamente iba a
hablar de el tema de la mujer en la
sociedad actual y la mujer dentro de la
iglesia que otros temas aparte de este
también todavía son deudas pendientes
Sí mira yo te diría Claro mi opinión tú
me pregunta mi opinión personal no yo
diría que el tema de género no de del de
la diversidad sexual
debiera tratarse de otra forma No de
otra forma Yo entiendo que Francisco
quien está
espontáneamente no esta opinión eso lo
han preguntado muchas veces quién soy yo
para juzgar y conversa con con un
jesuita en Estados Unidos con otro y se
abre al tema y está bien pero pero el
mundo y también no el mundo no la
iglesia no la iglesia pueblo de Dios
esperamos más no esperamos más porque
sabemos que la realidad es otra te das
cuenta su discurso no da cuenta de la
realidad sabemos que hay un clero que
pertenece a la diversidad sexual
Entonces yo diría que ese es un tema un
tema pendiente que hay que trabajarlo de
otra forma claro Pero insisto eso eso
requiere revisar fundamentos de la moral
de la moral sexual católica hay que
revisarla
no hay que adornarlo también Álvaro su
opinión sobre estas deudas pendientes
sí junto con lo anterior yo destacaría
la dificultad para la democratización de
la iglesia es decir no puede ser que la
estructura
eclesial no aplique los principios de
corresponsabilidad de subsidiaridad los
principios de autogobierno de la iglesia
locales yo creo que ahí hay un gran tema
pendiente que permitiría tener una
iglesia de Iglesias Ah que exista mucho
más autonomía las iglesias locales para
poder definir ciertos temas porque una
institución tan compleja tan diversa va
a poder avanzar en algunos lugares a un
paso más rápido y en otros lugares
tendrán el derecho a avanzar más lento y
juntos permanecer en la misma
institución eclesial pero esas pensiones
entre Alemania y una iglesia en África
que tiene otra concepción de la vida
sexual por ejemplo no se va a poder
gestionar en el futuro y eso solo se va
a resolver permitiendo que cada iglesia
local tenga niveles de decisión mayor de
la iglesia anglicana por ejemplo ha
permitido eso no ha generado niveles de
autonomía local para que decisiones de
este tipo se decidan autónomamente a
nivel nacional y eso permite cierta
cierta posibilidad de gestionar la
diversidad de posiciones en un mundo
Cada vez más
Álvaro hemos visto pues como lo
estábamos comentando el el papa habla de
diferentes temas no solamente de
coyuntura a nivel
social habla de fútbol también pero
también habla de política y uno de los
hechos recientes que vale la pena traer
al debate es esa ese tiro y afloje que
tiene con Nicaragua el papa calificó al
gobierno de Daniel Ortega como una
dictadura grosera la respuesta de
Managua fue cortar Los lazos
diplomáticos y a todo nivel con el
Vaticano se mete el papa también en
temas que no le conviene pronunciarse
sobre todo cuando hay un tema de
derechos humanos y de una población
vulnerable allí en Nicaragua y el papa
se lanza a hacer este tipo de
comentarios
yo creo que en eso ha sido una una voz
profética ya acompañado justamente a una
de las iglesias que más ha sufrido en
los últimos años en América Latina
recordemos la persecución que hizo el
régimen de Ortega al poeta y sacerdote
Ernesto cardenal privando lo de todos
sus derechos y después ahora con la
persecución encarcelamiento exilio de
obispos de la iglesia lo que nos
recuerda a otras figuras del continente
solamente en El Salvador ha habido casos
parecidos con Oscar Arnulfo Romero
asesinado en 1980 y ahora esta nueva
situación de persecución creo que lo
coloca en esa misma tradición no de
defensa de Quienes son hoy perseguidos
por su fe y creo que es un deber del del
Papa hacerlo denunciar esta persecución
Y colocar muy claramente en su contexto
lo que está ocurriendo en ese país Pedro
Pablo su opinión
Sí en realidad yo concuerdo con álvaros
y de hecho a mí me surge decir que por
ahí por ahí entra lo latinoamericanos
porque en América Latina la tradición
más rica no que viene de Puebla Medellín
Santo Domingo río aparecía es una
tradición donde donde la voz política no
desde la fe nunca ha estado ausente
nunca ha estado ausente no y hemos
tenido Obispo Mártires hemos tenido
religiosas asesinadas laicos campesinos
que han entregado su vida por meterse en
política desde desde el evangelio
entonces no es que el papa esté opinando
cosas que no debería hablar te das
cuenta a mí me parece extraordinario
y Y que siga denunciando la injusticia
el atropello de los Derechos Humanos
donde sea que ocurra y a mí también me
duele mucho la situación de Nicaragua es
un país donde tengo amigos y mucho
cariño por por el pueblo por la iglesia
y lo que está haciendo Ortega y no solo
Ortega no digamos su séquito realmente
es insostenible no e insostenible
entonces
a mí me parece que que ahí la iglesia
tiene un rol no tiene un rol y es una
voz más dentro del concierto democrático
de Voces entonces no es que la iglesia
no que hablen todas las iglesias que
hablen todas las instituciones que
quieran hablar después veremos
qué nos hace sentido no pero pero
estamos en un concierto Ah en un
concierto de la polis no el gran
concierto de la polis donde la iglesia
siempre ha tenido desde Jesús de Nazaret
una opinión que decir no olvidemos que
Jesús de Nazaret es un un atropellado
político no es un es un asesinado por
razones religiosas culturales y
políticas Sí vamos llegando ya al bloque
final del programa y tengo también que
preguntarles por esa relación que yo
todavía no podría definir si es una
buena relación o una relación un poco
tirante con su propio país con Argentina
ahora que se cumplen estos diez años han
salido todo este tipo de teorías y de
controversias en los medios argentinos
de Por qué el papa no ha visitado
argentina se ha visitado 60 países
alrededor del mundo a lo largo de estos
10 años hay quienes dicen que no quiere
meterse justamente en los temas
políticos de Argentina que no quiere
tener ninguna posición hay quienes lo
tildan de ser muy cercano al poder en
Argentina de tener algunos vínculos en
el pasado con el peronismo cosas que él
mismo ha desmentido en algún momento
pero por qué el papá no ha visitado
Argentina Porque el papá no ha ido a
reunirse con su pueblo más cercano más
inmediato que lo vio prácticamente nacer
dentro del tema religioso Y esa relación
distante pero amable pero como seca y
fría con Argentina comienzo con Álvaro
Mira yo creo que el papa se hace la
siguiente pregunta
el el viaje que podría realizar a un
determinado país contribuye o no a el
fortalecimiento de la iglesia a un mejor
clima político interno y a la
posibilidad de armonizar posiciones y
ser contra conductor de una cierta paz
Yo creo que España ya Argentina el papa
le debe un viaje pero tal vez las
condiciones de los países para recibirlo
no han sido adecuadas el caso de
Argentina creo que por la atención
política
del de Argentina en estos años donde él
ha sentido que lo han tratado de
manipular de una u otra forma ya sea A
favor o en contra de colocarse la
camiseta del papa en algunos lados o en
otros casos de considerarlo como un
enemigo y satanizarlo y en ese contexto
creo que ha tenido precaución y ha sido
prudente para no volver a Argentina
Yo creo que el desafío están los líderes
políticos argentinos para crear las
condiciones para ese viaje es decir la
pelota está en la cancha de los líderes
políticos de Argentina Sí hay quienes
dicen que el Papa Francisco es muy
consciente de ese uso político que puede
tener la imagen de él en una sociedad
como Argentina un país profundamente
polarizado o dividido con opiniones muy
muy diversas Pedro Pablo su opinión para
ir cerrando ya el programa
sí a mí hay una sensación de que el
último viaje de Francisco va a ser
Argentina
está este dicho más que conocido no que
nadie es profeta en su propia tierra
entonces evidente que Francisco
se le conoce desde otro punto de vista
no se le conoce desde que él era Jorge
Mario bergoglio Y antes no desde que era
un joven como cualquiera Entonces se
tiene algunas cosas que que causaron
heridas que causaron problemas no cuando
era superior de los Jesuitas y esa
historia la conocemos y es pública no
entonces sí Yo diría que hay prudencia
hay Quizá no sé una distancia
como dice Álvaro de no querer ser
manipulado en su en su rol en su figura
pero ahí me da la sensación de que el
papa sí quiere ir no y que está
esperando por eso yo me atrevería a
decir está esperando ya sea que renuncie
como el mismo lo ha dicho porque esa
puerta está abierta o que
él intuya que ya no va a poder viajar
mucho más y se va a ir a despedir de su
pueblo argentino no me cabe ninguna duda
de que el más del 50% del corazón del
Papa está en Argentina claro me queda un
minuto para finalizar el programa para
el cierre el papá Va a renunciar 86 años
de edad ya se le ve cansado físicamente
no es tan activo como Se le veía hace 10
años renunciará pronto qué análisis
pueden hacer ustedes rápidamente Álvaro
yo creo que no yo creo que está en un
proyecto ya Y eso lo motiva obviamente
podrían cambiar las condiciones físicas
y eso podría llevarlo a una renuncia
pero mientras mantenga la lucidez la
autoconciencia creo que lo veo
suficientemente convencido de llevar
adelante el proceso
A pesar de todo Sí y Pedro Pablo para el
cierre su conclusión
Yo espero que no pero un deseo más
personal por otro lado me parece
interesante
que el papa tenga la libertad de poder
renunciar si es que entiende que que ya
no puede continuar con su misión te das
cuenta decir esta cosa de la perpetuidad
del rol
no creo que sea necesaria Ya lo hizo
Benedicto XVI y Francisco quiere seguir
ese camino está muy bien No ahora bien
interesa su proyecto creo que está
haciendo bien Mientras más lo lo
mantenga lo perdure y lo establezca
mejor No mejor pues a Pedro Pablo de
Álvaro les agradezco mucho por este
análisis para la audiencia de France 24
es todo por el momento el nombre del
equipo técnico Les agradecemos a ustedes
la sintonía la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Luis Fernando Montes y
la producción de invitados a cargo de
Tania Herrera Gracias a ustedes por
vernos Pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios sigan con France 24
[Música]